>> Yes, I believe it's very possible for India
to become a superpower.
It's a tough trajectory, but I think you have
a lot of advantages.
Number one, you have a population of young
people coming up which
everybody knows is going to be the heart of
the energy of the country
and of innovation in the country.
If you manage this upcoming population, and
manage to channel those
energies appropriately into innovation, entrepreneurship,
et cetera,
and you create these structures, the innovation
frameworks that can
allow this to be sustainable, then I think
you have a very realistic
shot of becoming one of the world's superpower.
You're already on the way with a phenomenal
growth rate.
But that's not enough.
You need to create a lot of other systems
and infrastructures that are
going to enable this growth rate to be sustainable
in the way that the
superpowers have been able to do for themselves,
such as the United
States, and previously, although failed, the
Soviet union.
I think probably the model is one that's more
based on innovation,
science and technology-based innovation I
think is particularly
important and channelling the energy of your
youth, which you're going
to have a phenomenal advantage in.